[Musique]
bonjour faire leur donna bonjour
monsieur la ruche vous êtes vous un tous
les mots clés noah et à toutes les
banques chinoises qui m'écoutent
alors vous parlez de vos clients et vos
kinois parce que vous êtes évidemment
candidat aux élections municipales et
communautaires dans la ville du vauclin
vous êtes déjà conseiller municipal
d'opposition et vous êtes donc à la tête
de la liste présentée par le groupe
génération active je crois absolument
c'est ça c'est un groupe qui existe
depuis une dizaine d'années et nous
sommes cinq au conseil municipal dans un
groupe constitué un groupe qui exercent
une opposition assez sérieuse il me
semble à la majorité actuelle
voilà alors donc vous y retournez
puisque vous étiez candidat en 2014
bien sûr pourquoi pourquoi parce que en
2020 parce que
nous estimons que le bilan de l'équipe
sortante n'est pas satisfaisant et puis
nous avons fait un travail considérable
pendant les six dernières années nous
avons déjà un acquis puisque en 2014
nous avons fait un certain nombre de
voix ne me vois très important pas assez
pour remporter l'élection mais enfin
assez conséquent donc nous estimons que
nous sommes légitimes à revenir ou à la
bataille avec cette fois ci beaucoup
plus d'atouts beaucoup plus d'expérience
et puis surtout le soutien me
semble-t-il d'une grande grande partie
de la population aujourd'hui le maire
raymond occolier le maire sortant donc
ne se représente pas en revanche son
premier adjoint entendu succéder comment
vous envisagez ça justement le fait que
ce soit un des poids-lourds finalement
l'équipe sortante qui donc oui faut
continuer quoi alors la problématique
est la même pour nous puisque
cet homme représente le groupe politique
qu'il incarne depuis 25 ans en comptant
de monsieur kleinau absolument si ce
n'est pas un novice c'est quelqu'un qui
a 25 années d'exercice du pouvoir plus
quinze années de l'exercice de
l'opposition donc ça fait quand même 40
ans de vie politique sur le vauclin ils
se sont c'est un homme qui a suivi pas à
pas monsieur au collier donc c'est c'est
la même équipe et je pense en tous les
cas d'après les premières bribes de ce
que j'ai entendu il défend bec et ongles
le bilan de son équipe ce qui est très
bien puisque justement c'est ce bilan
que nous attaquons ce n'est pas une
affaire d'hommes c'est une affaire de
politique qu'ils menaient qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus emblématique selon vous
a attaqué à dénoncer de ce qui s'est
passé
moi qui ai fait un peu de bruit dans le
micro de ce qui s'est passé au cours des
six dernières années le fait que en 2020
nous avons encore des endroits au
vauclin où les gens n'ont pas l'eau
courante
je veux parler des quartiers bour et les
dames par exemple vous avez des endroits
où les gens n'ont pas la population n'a
pas de la responsabilité directe de la
municipale bien il me semble oui et même
si effectivement l'ex 6 me
actuellement la communauté de l'espace
sud ont une responsabilité il appartient
à l'édilité de pousser son dossier est
de faire en sorte que les la population
soit satisfaite dans ses demandes et je
termine en disant qu' il n'est pas
normal qu'en 2020 il ya des endroits il
y ait des endroits où il n'y a pas
d'électricité courante je parlais de
l'extrémité
deux cocottes je veux parler d'une
pointe de bd mulet du côté de dix
failles je veux parler de petit pérou
du côté de la beaujolaise tout un
ensemble de secteurs ou des équipements
finalement qui paraît ce basique
n'existe pas en 2020
et puis je ne peux pas ne plus lui non
plus une venir à de votre micro pour ne
pas parler de la situation financière du
vauclin qui n'est pas catastrophique
mais qui est quand même préoccupante
on a un endettement qui est conséquent
qui va nous lier je les dis sur d'autres
plateaux pieds et poings pendant au
moins trois quatre ans parce que la
commune un taux d'endettement qui très
important et la somme disponible pour
investir dans les dents lit dans le
programme qu'on voudrait développer sera
relativement faibles donc il nous
appartiendra de faire preuve de
d'ingéniosité pour aller chercher les
financements et puis surtout de faire
des arbitrages sur les manifestations
qui sont actuellement en cours alors
vous avez fait la transition toute
trouvée est un peu de temps mais bon
compte tenu des moyens contre 1 auquel
vous venez de faire allusion
j'imagine que vous n'avez pas eu de
multiples projets propositions pour la
mandature qui vient si vous êtes venus
alors si oui a quand même quelques
chantiers que donc je dirais très
important exemple ils sont tous a priori
terre une population a besoin de
travailler donc nous avons dans notre
projet une ambitieuse
création de zones d'activités une
population a besoin de se loger nous
avons également dans notre projet
voulait concernant l'accession à la
propriété pour les ménages à revenus les
plus importants une population a besoin
de solidarité nous avons les tensions
dans notre projet de développer à
l'intention de nos aînés en tous les cas
de d'initier la création d'une maison
pour nos aînés d'une maison de retraite
comme on dit une population a besoin
aussi d'éducation
donc on a un volet interne et pour les
petits à part la création il se sera la
création de la première crèche
municipale du vauclin merci fernando n'a
on l'a pas précisé en début d'entretien
mais vous êtes également conseiller
communautaire à l'espace sud
merci beaucoup monsieur k o voilà merci
fernando n'a candidat donc au vauclin
pour les élections municipales et
communautaires